denise pfizer is one step closer to
getting their covet 19 vaccine approved
for children the process hasn't been
finalized but it is a crucial move
forward christian cosrus joins us live
in our studio with who could benefit
from this and when it would potentially
roll out christian well brian pfizer
bioin tech says a lower dose of the
coronavirus vaccine is safe for children
as young as five years old now if
approved the vaccine could be available
close to halloween pfizer says its covet
19 vaccine works for children 5 to 11
years old and that it will seek u.s
authorization for this age group very
soon currently the pfizer vaccine is
available for 12 and older unlv's
epidemiologist brian laba said it's
unclear at this point if the vaccine
would be a yearly requirement once it's
approved not only will it help reduce
cases in the community in general it's
going to help reduce transmission in
schools that's one of our big concerns
we have a lot of kids in close contact
and it's very disruptive when you have
somebody who's positive in the classroom
because a lot of kids get sent home so
this gives us the opportunity to protect
kids and keep schools open in person
pfizer says the lower two shot dosage
has been proven to be safe with similar
or fewer temporary side effects like
sore arms fever or achiness according to
the american academy of pediatrics more
than 5 million children in the u.s have
tested positive for covet 19 since the
pandemic began and more than 450 have
died the delta variant being blamed for
the spread
well according to new cdc data almost
half of teens in the country are fully
vaccinated now meanwhile pfizer and
moderna are said to also be studying
younger children as young as six months
those results expected later this year
christian casadas 8 news now and
christian with pfizer's announcement
today we asked you on twitter do you
plan to have your child vaccinated at
least 58 percent say yes and 42 say no